hang on didn't we just do this so war
just came down that director Colin
Trevorrow is leaving Star Wars Episode
nine and I'm getting off quickly
distinct feeling of deja boo' all of a
sudden with this whole thing kind of
happening again I mean it's not it's not
exactly the same as the Han Solo thing
actually it's it's fairly different all
things considered because that film was
in mid production when they chucked the
directors and brought in a new one
whereas this one hadn't actually started
filming yet they're actually still in
the scripting phase and I think the
first sign of trouble was they brought a
new writer in to work on rewrites guess
about a month ago
like I'm not particularly familiar with
he's mostly done British television Jack
Thorne I think was his name but I mean
that I didn't say anything about that
because I didn't assume it to be an
implication of anything but that I guess
that was step one and it did one would
extrapolate and I got most of what I'm
gonna say aside from just the fact that
he's off the project is all speculation
on my part cuz we don't know exactly
what went down if I were to guess it's
gotta be issues with the story and with
the scripting and with what he wanted to
do as far as the stories he wanted to
tell and the thing was when he was
assigned to this project I got nervous
not because of him as a director but the
fact that he was gonna be crafting the
story because calm Trevor Rose best
movie safety not guaranteed he didn't
write the script for and and the thing
that he's best known for Jurassic world
which made a ton of money and was fun
but was also very very very stupid he
did work on the script for so I it
struck me as odd that he was brought in
to both write and direct Episode nine
when in my head it would have made more
sense just to have him direct and have
someone else script and maybe it was his
condition that he was gonna work on the
story maybe they thought he had a good
initial pitch and it just wasn't coming
together but it would appear that
whatever story he wanted to tell they
were going this isn't working we need to
do something else and which I would then
yes at that point he said well if I'm
not gonna get to do the story that I
wanted to do I just don't think this is
a good thing for me to do and they left
there saying and Michael iam sure there
was some level of tension but certainly
handle much much better than the whole
Lord Miller thing and looking at it in
isolation it's not a huge deal all
things considered it's early enough in
the project I mean I with episode 8 the
last Jedi coming out this year I would
think they'd like to get rolling a
little bit further along then you know
having to find a new director and all
that but you know it's not the end of
the world that doesn't throw things into
utter turmoil so I guess what makes it
interesting is more just the pattern and
the level of control that Lucasfilm and
Kathleen Kennedy seemed to be wanting to
to exert over the Star Wars franchise
and the the picture we have becomes
fairly consistent in terms of wrote one
Gareth Edwards goes in shoots his
version of rogue one that he wanted to
do they screen it it's not Star Wars II
enough there's massive reshoots and even
though I like the finished result of row
1 you can see that you can see the
stitches on how the thing was put back
together and really doesn't truly hit
its stride until it gets into the third
act and you can you can feel the weight
of the rewrites in it so there was that
then there was the Han Solo movie Lord
Millar completely booted because they
are used to a very freeform just getting
to do their own thing and it wasn't
gelling but the fact that they were
given a script that had that all of the
producers in Kathleen Kennedy and and
and Lawrence Kasdan all those folks
really were committed to the script and
they gave it to guys who don't stick to
a script so that was that just seemed
like a bad pairing and now we've got
Trevor o going again it seems to be
coming from just him not being on the
same page as as the the folks at the top
are and it's creating a consistent
pattern a pretty consistent narrative
except for one thing and that is that
Rian Johnson writer and director on the
last Jedi coming out later this year
he's gone on record and say they just
left him alone he had almost no
interference from what he's saying now I
will grant as possible he's saying that
to be diplomatic maybe there was some
level of interference except she's never
struck me as the Stute as the studio
stooge kind of guy he's he's really
forged his own path up to this point so
I don't see him playing that game so
maybe that was just a case of getting
just the perfect guy on it that what he
wanted to do was exactly in line with
what Kathleen Kennedy and the others
were gonna be happy with and it just
happened to work out perfect that time
and the other times that they got people
with their own ideas what those ideas
were want what they wanted so I mean
obviously we're episodes 9 so it's still
gonna happen it's it's not like the DC
movies when one of the you know various
films that are is in some level of
production loses a director becomes a
question are they ever actually gonna
get to make that which seems to be what
keeps happening with a flash movie and
who knows whatever else I mean episode 9
is going to happen there's absolutely no
question that episode 9 is going to
happen so you know they'll get a
director on it they'll make that but so
the question then becomes is what the
Star Wars look like after that how do
they shape it after that because I don't
think Kathleen Kennedy has a ton of
ideas of like what she thinks the story
should be but I think like like that
sort of classic line I don't know art
but I know what I like I have a feeling
she knows that when what she's given
isn't what she wanted even if she
doesn't have the storytelling writing
directing chops to craft what the story
should be she keeps running into people
presenting her with things she thinks it
shouldn't be and I keep singling her out
because she is the head of Lucasfilm and
her name's gonna keep popping up and it
may not be her exclusively obviously
Lawrence Kasdan a was of probably a very
vocal voice in terms of Lord Miller cuz
he wrote that script that everybody was
on board with so she's not the only
voice so when I say her I really just
mean Lucasfilm so maybe I'll start
saying that instead of singling her out
because then then it maybe it's making
it a little bit too personal but it's
funny increasingly I think we're seeing
the difficulties of trying to do not
only
big interconnected movies but have them
come out at a rapid pace
because when productions are sort of
just stacking on top of each other when
things kind of grind to a halt it
impacts a lot of other stuff and I
brought this up before when I talked
about the defenders and how if things
have been more spaced out and then that
show could have been adjusted more based
off the feedback and a lot of the gripes
people had about iron fists and a lot of
issues even with like structurally with
Luke Cage issues that were repeated with
the defenders because that thing was so
far along in production by the time
reaction to those series came out they
couldn't change it your they weren't
able to respond to things so we're
seeing where the cracks are where the
faults are in this way of filmmaking or
television making in the case of the
Marvel Netflix stuff but this this sort
of entertainment way of going about
building a universe and especially
trying to do it really rapid-fire we're
seeing where these things can fall down
I think we may not be too far off from
most of the major studios I'm not gonna
say abandoning the interconnected
universe thing but dialing it back
Star Wars is kind of stuck with it
because the movies have always been
interconnected but I have a feeling that
after episode 9 they're not gonna crank
out you know whatever the next trilogy
is two years after that bed they'll
probably give it a little bit more
breathing room based off what their
experience has been trying to get a Star
Wars movie out every single year maybe
they'll realize that that speed isn't
just isn't working it isn't
accommodating the people who want to be
involved in making these movies or it's
putting people in a position who maybe
aren't the best fit or things of that
nature and I mean I marvel we'll stay
with it because they seem to be the ones
that make it work but even even them
like guys like I'm saying there we're
seeing some of the issues with it and I
part of me really does expect for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe to start to
slowly grind to a halt after we get
whichever Avengers movie fan OHS gets
completely taken care of in because
that's the thing that's been building up
to forever and then once that's done
okay we'll be around this'll be fun but
I wouldn't be surprised if things break
away more into individual franchises
more as opposed to trying to be this big
cohesive thing again and I think DC's
already headed that way with you know
talk of an else world style Joker and
you know doing flashpoint and possibly
using that as a way to reset things and
just sort of distancing these things
from each other because it's the it's
the combination of the
interconnectedness and trying to get
these things out so rapidly that is
starting to trip these Studios up and
they're at this point they are tripping
more often than they are clearing the
hurdles and like I said it's the news in
and of itself for Star Wars Episode nine
I don't think is that exceptional but it
is a pattern now it's a pattern for Star
Wars as a franchise and it's a pattern
it's becoming a pattern for cinematic
universes as a thing I just can't help
but think that when audiences either get
bored with them or feel that they've got
too convoluted to be worth really
following everything that's involved in
them anymore they're just not gonna be
worth the bother anymore I'm not sure
they're gonna explode or fall apart in
any sort of spectacular
you know trainwreck kind of fashion I
thought it'll just be more of a slow
decline as Studios realize you know we
could keep trying to do this but
audiences don't seem to care let's find
something else which is the way
Hollywood tends to work it grinds an
idea into the ground until it's not as
profitable as something else might be
and then they go back to trying to find
out what the next big thing is gonna be
which for my money if they ever crack
how to do video game adaptations
correctly that's probably gonna be the
next big well that they'll go to but I
they keep you keep coming up snake eyes
on that one big time and I predicted
before that they will continue to
although the video games into serialized
form into Netflix or TV shows that might
actually work
but now I'm tangent day and again I
think I'm tangent
the specific news about Star Wars itself
is ok that's the thing that happened but
it puts me more into a mind of looking
at the overall trends of just sort of
these exercises in brand building and
brand management and cinematic universes
that studios have really gone in for
that yeah this isn't gonna work forever
and I think we're we're starting to see
that and so some be a company like
Lucasfilm which at this point until they
revive Indiana Jones and you know the
few other things
yeah and Willow Lucasfilm is the Star
Wars studio that is what they are so
they've got all their efforts in on this
and they're gonna have to make the
decision do we ease off a little bit and
accept these filmmakers to make whatever
it is they want to make and except that
it may not be exactly what we want or do
we put a death grip on it and make sure
we're only hiring people who are going
to deliver exactly what they want
because they've been trying to kind of
split the difference it looks like and
that hasn't worked because you can
either do the Marvel approach which is
to get people largely from television
who are used to just doing you know a
couple of episodes in somebody else's
bigger vision but you get you know
visually talented good storytellers from
television who are used to not having
total control over the vision of the
thing and they'll slot in really easily
and then you can maintain a pretty tight
level of control or you can do what DC
used to do before they got into the DC
EU exercise and they now seem to be
going back to which is get visionary
directors and let them do their thing
and don't mess with it overly I mean
that's how we got Burton's Batman that's
how we got Nolan's Batman that's how we
got Snyder's Watchmen so
those are the kind of the two approaches
and lucasfilm's seem to be splitting the
difference because they were bringing in
directors with vision but then trying to
force them into a box and that doesn't
work and I think that that's also the
mistake the DC made I think that's a big
part of what led to things like Suicide
Squad because David Ayer is a guy with a
really specific voice and a really
strong one and they told him it's gotta
be pg-13 you have six weeks to write the
script and we're gonna come in and have
a trailer company recut it after the
fact like no no you bring in a guy like
this you need to let him you need to
step back and let him do his thing and
if you're not gonna step back and let
them do his thing bring in somebody else
and I will be curious to see who Luke is
film puts on episode nine after this and
I will like I said I will be curious to
see what they go on moving forward if
they're smart they're gonna take a break
after episode nine not necessarily from
spin-off stuff cuz you know we'll have
the obi-wan movie we'll have other stuff
but they'll put longer than a two-year
gap before they do another numbered main
saga movie I think that would be the
smart thing to do so those are my
rambling thoughts kind of going all over
the place about what happened with Star
Wars Episode nine and sort of what it
makes me think about the state of things
in general in Hollywood right now so
that will just about wrap it up what are
your thoughts on all of this whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen to the Council of geeks podcast
I'm also 1/2 of the punch like a girl
podcast both available on iTunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]